[Music]
Britney Spears ended 2017 on a high note
which she ended her Las Vegas residency
last night I saw the show twice during
her run she was so fabulous her show at
Planet Hollywood began in 2013 it has
topped 100 million dollars in ticket
sales now if you didn't get to see
Britney don't worry there are still a
lot of big names playing in Sin City
this year Lady Gaga is bringing her
poker face to Vegas the ink is dry on
her new residency deal her shows will
debut in December at MGM's Park Theatre
so what makes these residency so
irresistible to a list artists reasons
Gaga reportedly had 75 million reasons
to say yes that is what she's said to be
earning over the course of her two-year
deal and 2018 will be the last chance to
see J Lo's all I have Planet Hollywood
residency it was recently announced her
last performance will be September 29th
Caesars Palace Colosseum's reigning
queen Celine Dion has performed for over
4 million fans since launching her show
in 2003 Dion recently announced she's
adding 26 more shows through June Vegas
has given us an opportunity to give the
fans things that you cannot travel with
on the road that sentiment is shared by
fellow icon Lionel Richie in March he
will be splitting time between his all
the hits Planet Hollywood show in Vegas
with his American Idol judging gig all
the hits is back in Vegas you know what
I feel like this is a great destination
because it's in one place and I get to
kind of enjoy the show see the crowd I
can hear them and at the end if it's a
break in between I can go home just
right down the street
[Music]
you